alors dorothée on arrive à un dur moment
maintenant c'est les fameuses questions
cons à lola ohlala alors ça commence
simplement des jarretelles ou koh lanta
c'est un collant bon d'accord t'es
soutien gorge ou sein du bois où tu sais
j'ai pas avons toujours trouvé un hatay
c'était le jir que la tessin et tu veux
dire par ce mur est ce que tu es slip ou
caleçon quel chouette
ah ouais j'ai fait ça dès qu'elle ferait
tout pas mal oui c'est du calisson sous
cette robe non pas question d'aider des
grands âges un grand machin est ce que
tu préfèrerais marion des dentelles soit
machin non non pas du comprendre tu dis
que tu arrives pas être mariée mais tu
comprends c'est celui-ci tu disais me
dire tu préfèrerais mourir rayon laser
bombe à neutrons ou gaz inodore
en laser ça c'est du spectacle c'est
bien malgache gaz inodore tu avais pas
je pense
si tu pouvais continuer à en croire vos
invités j'ai alors imaginé imagine que
tu sois coincés dans un ascenseur déjà
imagine que tu sois accrochée c'était
dans un ascenseur qui préférait être
coincé avec qui catherine lara muriel
robin ou marie paule belle
je ne sais pas choisissant une un
ascenseur c'est pour une navette
spatiale qui parle d'un serpent des
histoires ah ouais muriel robin avec toi
dans un ascenseur pendant qu'en même
temps tu tiendras déboires ces attaques
alors ton jules n'y arrive pas imagine
c'est une supposition tout ça c'est des
questions qui position suppositions ton
julie arrives pas tu lui demande comment
elle s'appelle premières suppositions
deuxième suppositions tu lui fais un
truc spécial pour qu'ils y arrivent
troisièmes suppositions tu te casses en
claquant la porte
ado n'en ait eu de quatre flacons la
poche papa apports dont j'ai mon garde
du temps va mais on verra donc la
question suivante j'aimerais bien être
la pause est pas ici quoi pas de vent
pas devant tout le monde peut wallonie
voilà pas loin d'accord c'est bien ok
ouais 10 - dorothée si tu devais partir
sur une sur une île déserte
tu choisirais qui entre de chavannes de
caunes
près des deux terrains au moins tu
prends la clé je suis obligé de dire toi
non franchement du franchement pas de
quoi être triste mais vrai tu prends moi
que c'est pas tirer une semaine sur des
dessertes avec moi mais ce n'est pas là
un budget de miser sur les joueurs
promis oui quand même
on y retourne pas laisser tout seul noir
comme elle
et je te dirai que c'est bon bon mois
ouais je crois que c'est bon pour moi
j'essaie de rouler une pelle ça n'a pas
marché mais j'ai une ouverture mais
c'est vous
bon